では 今年も三宝に守られて大変良い年でありますようにと
深みの祈願をいたします
今日の話はこれから始まります
今日のテーマはブッダと脳というね
心はどこで成長するのかということで
いわゆる心の成長の仕組みについて喋りたいんです
あって 今のきっかけになったのはね
まあ英語では結構前から出てきていた本にぶつかりましてね
脳科学とね 仏教の心理学的なね
話を合わせたものとかね
で それからこれ 最近日本語訳も出まして
まあそれで関係のある方々は興味を持ったようなものなんですけど
それにこの私が話になる前に
この現代脳科学者の方々は一応唯脳論を語っているんですね
すべて脳の働きで説明できますと
人間の活動一切は ということで
すべて脳だけですよというふうに脳みそ信仰になっているんですね
で 最初は私はすっごくおかしいと
この連中はね 思ってはいたんですけど
まあどうせ科学者はおかしくなければ科学者でもないしね
で しかし やっぱりどんどん機械は開発されていかれて
病気な人間だけではなくて
普通の健康な人間の脳の働きも調べる調べられるようになったんですね
で まあそれならね ごく一般的な人々の脳の働きはそのままいろいろ実験できるし
調べることもできるし
まあそれなら説明はいくらかまあ聞いても構わないではないかなという気分にはなっていたんですね
しかし 何でもかんでも脳であるというっても
仏教っていうのはまともに違う立場なんですね
脳はただの体の一部で
脳みそ はい これで話終わり
釈尊の心の科学では 体の一部であるのを参考にしてないんですね
心の説明になると 全く脳に参考にしてないんです
しかし お釈迦様には勝てないと思いますけど
お釈迦様はね まあ心ってどこにあるのかい？というね
いうことも一応微妙に
ほんのちょっとわずかな説明はあります
で 心はどこにあるのかという場合は
脳みそだとは言ってないんですね
その代わりにはだやというはだやというのはまた心臓の心なんですね
と同じ単語を使っているんですね
心臓にははだやとパーリ語で言うんですね
心にもはだやと言うんですね
結局は日本の人たちも同じ感じですからね
心臓と心ですからね まあ東洋ではそんな脳みそのこと考えてなかった可能性はあります
医学の世界でもね 脳はそんなに昔の人間の脳をいかれなかったんだから
体の治療はあったんですけど
脳の治療っていうのはそんなになかったんですね
薬はあります でも脳の機能を改善する薬はあります
あの 今もあります 売ってますね
記憶力を高める薬とかね
まあ結構お母さんたちは子供たちに飲ませてますけどね
まあ別にただの植物ですからね
まあよくわかりませんですけどね
で 体に悪いものは入ってないんですけど
しかし 脳の手術とかね
そこまでは問題はなかったんですね
それからお釈迦様は心臓はどこかといったら
胃じゃなくて心はどこかといったらはだやですよと言って
はだやの説明になってくると
ある物質に依存して人間の認識機能が働くんだよと
この認識機能が働くとき依存する物質はハデヤであって
それは心の住処であると
で それがこのハデヤという言葉ですから
注釈書になってくると
ヒンドゥー教のバラモン教のサルマに応じて
心は心臓にあるんだと言ってるんですね
これは現代的に見ればなんかおかしいですね
心臓に心があると言ったってもね
で それで私は経典を調べたら
お釈迦様は心臓にあるとは言ってないんです
脳みそとも言ってないんですね
まあ心も何か物質に依存して住処にして働いてますよと
物質というのは体の肉体の一部ですね
そういうわけで  脳ということは否定してないんです
心は肉体と区別できる働きという立場で説明されています
とにかくお釈迦様から見れば
肉体には肉体の働きがあって
心には特別区別できる働きがありますよと
よくよく見ると 肉体の働きよりは心の働きは派手なんですね
生きるということは簡単に心が働いていることだからね
考えるは喋るは 仕事をするは
いろんなことをやって生きているんだから
肉体よりは心の方が多いんですね
しかし 肉体の道具として使わなくちゃいけない
喋りたくなったら やっぱり体を使って喋らなくちゃいけないし
何か作りたくなったら体を使ってそれを作らなくちゃいかないんだけど
体を動かしているのは誰ですかと
やっぱりそれは心が動かしているんですね
だからはっきり別に区別はできます
では 正しいのは現代科学
あるいはブッダの心理学ということになるんですね
現代科学者はもうすべて脳であると
別に心はありませんというふうに言っていて
脳を解析すれば全部わかりますよと
お釈迦様は参考もしていないんです
じゃあ誰が正しいんですかね
そういうわけで 心の定義に入ってみます
心の定義はアーラマニビジャヤラッカナチッタンという文章で
対象を知る機能が心という定義なんですね
知る機能ですね 要するに知るという働きが
ファンクションが心なんですね
だからわざとものを探するのは
あれは西洋人のやり方なんですね
何かものがなければ 現代唯物科学には測れませんね
電波もものですからね
信号ものですから 何かものが欲しいんですね
機能だけということは
ちょっとだから機能科学はいっぱいあるのに
機能だけで理論するのはできないみたいですね
見て物理学っていうのはもうほとんど機能学でしょうしね
物理と言ったっても もうたくさん枝分かれになってるでしょうに
物理学は ほとんどいろいろファンクションの機能の働きばっかり研究しているんですけど
なんかものが必要なんですね
仏教はものがなくて知るということが心ですよとしているんです
ものではありません で
生きているものの場合は
一 自分を知っている 私たちは自分を知っています
この肉体を 二 周りを知ってるんですね
外の世界は これは仏教の瞑想の場合でも
アッジャってバヒダという内と外
内と外とずっと分かれているんですね
分けて分けるんですよ
瞑想する時でも 四念処経の瞑想でも
必ずアッチャって場合で
内と外 内と外と見なさいと
だから内も見られるで
外も見られるんですね
うーん この知る機能なんですね
また定義あります 生きるとは命
生命とは 生きるとは 命とは
生命とは知る機能があるという意味なんです
だから仏教の場合 この生命の定義なんですね
生き物とは何ぞやと 知る機能がある場合は生き物であると
で これはもっと精密に言えば感覚
感じる機能があれば それが生命です
感じる機能がなければ物質です
物体です テレビは物体で
パソコンも物体で いろいろデータに反応するんだからといって
感じる機能はないんです
皆様の携帯はね 電波に反応しますけど
生き物ではありません
で 感覚があるんですね
それで生命ですね 仏教は脳細胞
脳みそがあれば生命ですとは言ってないんです
だからアメーバも生命なんですよ
もう感じるんですよ 生命のすべてに心という機能があるが
脳細胞があるとは言えませんね
そこで科学世界がミスったところなんですね
人間が神の子だから特別扱いしてるんです
非科学的に 迷信的に 生物学ですからね
人間分析していても で
科学者もミミズもね で
この何て言いますか 海に生活しているね
まあイソギンチャクやらいろいろ単細胞やらいっぱいいるでしょ
あれはちゃんと生命だと定義しているでしょ
その場合はまた物質で定義するんですよ
あのなんかのなんかありますね
クロロフィルという何か細胞に入って
それは植物なんですね
緑のもの 葉緑素 葉緑素
で それがあると太陽と合成して自分でエネルギー作るんですね
それは植物 それがない場合はもう普通の生命なんですね
物で定義するんです 物質で
仏教はやっぱり機能で定義するんですね
感じる機能があれば生命ですと
だからもし植物にも感じる機能があれば知ったことじゃないんですよ
生命になるんです だからなかなかそれ調べる方法ないだけなんですね
だから感じる機能がある植物も
感じる機能がない植物もありますよ
必ず生命は外から栄養を取らなくちゃあかんと決まりがないんだから
自分で自己発生して栄養を取ることもできます
そういう生命事件もいます
人間に見えないんですけど
はい それで あの 生命のすべてに心という機能があるんです
しかし 生命すべてに脳がないんです
ということで 有脳論では生命を脳説明はできません
あまりにもいい加減というか
なんかちょっと子供っぽいですね
いうのを考え方は 人間の働きが脳のファンクションで説明できまってるだけの話なんです
したがって心は脳であるっていうのはいい加減にしなさいよと
その調子で言ってみたら
やっぱり認められましたからね
自分たちはいい加減だと
仏教の心理学は一切生命の心の説明です
仏教の心理学っていうのは
人間の心の分析じゃないんです
生命の一切の生命の心の働きなんですね
だから仏教には脳中心には語るわけにはいきません
かなりスケールを大きく分析しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから仏教の心理学はすべての生命に当てはまりますよ
犬猫にも微生物にも もう神々にも
もう霊とかいるならば
幽霊でもね どちらにでも当てはめます
どちらにでも当てはまります
だから私から私の感じで言えば
お釈迦様はあえてわざと心を別な働きとしてわざと区別したんです
一緒にしちゃえばまずいやと
もうガタガタの説明になるんだと
不完全な説明になるんだというところなんです
だから ナーマとループ
名色とはっきりと存在を分けてありますね
生命の一部だけに限ったものではないと
まあまあ言いましたからね
仏教の心理学は生命の一部に限ったものではないんです
我々勉強している現代心理学は
人間の心の働きだけですね
ですから 仏教は有頂論とは合致しません
仏教心理学は これちょっと間違えますね
この最初の字は間違ってます
最初からも現代心理学の範囲を超えているんです
心の清浄 成長 向上 人格完成
智慧の開発 苦しみを乗り越える解脱などは現代心理学の管轄ではありません
現代心理学は偉そうにあれやこれやと膨大に喋るわ
喋るは喋るは もう何兆も金かかって研究するわ
でも全然助けになってないんです
人類の 金の戻す会なんです
事業仕分けにした方がいいと思いますけどね
仏教は心の清浄 成長 向上
まあまあ同義語ばかりですけどね
人格完成 智慧の開発 苦しみを乗り越えること
解脱という境地 そういうことを提案するんですよ
心理学で いわゆる人間にすごい大事なことを教えてくれるんです
頑張りなさいよと ただ俺が知ってる
すごいこと知ってるんだよというふうなね
まあ知ったかぶりを示すために心理学を語っているわけじゃないんです
しかし 現代知識は仏教を理解する上では大いに役に立ちます
これで誤解になるのは
この合致しないとだけですけど
まるっきり反対ってわけじゃないんです
なぜならば 科学者も真剣に調べて語っているんですよ
気持ち言ってるわけじゃないんです
ちゃんとデータ取るんです
ちゃんと調べるんです
ですから 調べて言ってるんだから
その調べたところは仏教の話に合うんです
それから科学者がちょっと飛び出すんですね
余計に一歩飛び出すんですね
いつでもそれ飛ぶんですよ
迷信でむすっと飛んじゃうんです
で いくつかの体の心の機能が脳で説明できちゃったんですね
それでいきなり飛んじゃって
すべて脳だけであると
脳以外何でもないんだと
あんた証明していないでしょうに
そんなことは 飛ぶなよと
どうしても飛んじゃいますよ
で もう月で水を見つけた見つけたとかね
もう火星で水が見つけたとかね
氷が見つけたとかね まあまあ 10
キロ20キロぐらいとかね
はい これで次に飛ぶんですよ
それで向こうでもうみんな住んで
もう地下の水をくみ上げて
あれやこれやとかストーリーまで作っちゃうんだ
そんなとこじゃないんだから
まだ何もろくに知らないんだから
次のこと はい そういう問題だけなんですよ
でないと まあ調べられてるところは未だすべてブッダの教えたものとは合ってます
調べたところでは 脳生理学的に物理学の説明もね
まあそれを種の働きもね
まあ私は読んでみたんだけど
やっぱりわからなかったんですけど
やっぱりわかった範囲で見たら
やっぱり仏教の説明とは全然合わないということはないんですね
しかし 全部そちら説明されてはないんです
では 人間の体の説明に行きます
人間の体 細胞の働きですね 60
兆の細胞はある はある意味で単独で生きていると言えます
これはもう私の主観的な科学です
だから別に科学にならなくてもいいんです
私も勝手です で 細胞はそれぞれ自分勝手に生きているのではないかと
しかし 一 他の細胞の協力
助けが必要です 目の細胞
皮膚の細胞あれやこれや
自分たちで勝手に生きているんです
単立的に60兆の細胞は
問題がありますよ 他の細胞の助けが助けがなければ成り立ちません
例えば髪の毛っていうのは
体のどんな細胞とも全然違うでしょうに
似ていないでしょう 自分たちが別世界でしょ
皆様勝手にね 髪の毛の色を変えたりするでしょう
同じことを皮膚にやってみたらどうですかね
大変なことになりますよ
どこに行っても別に髪があっても生きていられるし
髪がなくても生きていられるしね
だから私は髪を剃りますからね
そんな髪が薄くなることをそんなに困らなくてもいいんですけど
生きていられますよ 私にもここら辺で今もうピカピカ光ってますけど
全然気にしません 私は便利やと
カミソリを引く面積が少なくなりましたと
で だからなんで髪の毛や体だけがあるのかいと
やっぱりそいつらがそいつらで勝手にできてるんです
しかし勝手に生きてるんだけど
他の細胞の協力が欠かせません
2番目は 各細胞にも他の細胞のために果たさなくてはいけない義務があるんです
だから我々アパートを借りたことと同じなんですよ
アパートは自分自由自在に生きていればいいんだけど
やっぱりアパートを貸してくれた人に家賃を払わないとね
水道代とか電気代とか電話代払わないとね
ちょっと困っちゃいますね
そんな感じなんですよ
だから各細胞はちゃんと水道代
電気代払ってるんです
他の細胞に だから細胞にはそれぞれの専門職があるんです
で 昔は髪の毛と体の毛にも仕事ありましたし
今はないんだけど 歯の歯には歯の仕事はあるし
白衣には白衣の仕事があるんです
大腸の小腸の細胞には全く別な仕事があるんです
小腸細胞をやってる仕事は皮膚の細胞にはできません
心臓細胞にも別な仕事
みんな専門職ですよ みんなそれぞれプロですね
だからプロとして自分の仕事をする
その代わりに他の細胞の協力いただいて
自分たちが独立して生きている
これが人間の命なんですね
他の生命も同じことでしょう
この関係が機能する場合は順調です
我々は順調というのは
細胞たちが自分勝手で
まあおとなしく生活する
同時に自分の専門職もやっている
そこまでは順調です 自分がアパートを借りて
まあ水道代も電気代も全部払って
家賃も払ってはいるんだけど
家の中でひどい臭いがするように料理を作ったり
犬を飼って犬がワンワン鳴いたり
夜12時でガンガンステレオをかけたりしちゃうと
隣からクレームが来て
もしかすると警察も呼ばれたりして
もしかすると追い出される可能性ありますね
その時は順調じゃないんですね
時々我々の体の細胞もそういうことをやっちゃいます
ずいぶん勝手にやろうとするんです
そうすると病院に行って
これ取り出してくださいと
と言っちゃいます だから大腸細胞は大腸細胞しないで自分だけ成長しちゃうと
がんですからね 捨てられます
これが命ですね はい では脳のテーマに入ります
脳の機能と心の成長 私は今日スライド書いてないんだけど
これ言いたかったんですよ
脳細胞も細胞ですよと
それぞれ勝手に生きているんだと
勝手に生きているんだけど
家賃を払わなくちゃいけないんですね
だから脳細胞は他の細胞の
あの 何といいますか セントラルコマンドというかね
コマンドセントラルですね
全部司令部として 収穫部として
じゃあ私はみんなをまとめてマネージメントやりますと
マネージャーですよ  別に他の細胞なければマネージャーに何の立場もないでしょうに
銀行はないんだけど 銀行のマネージャーいると言ったってもね
笑 笑える話でしょ 私は総理大臣ですけど
国はありませんと言ったら意味がないでしょ
ですから 脳細胞はそんなにすごいのかという仏教の立場なんですね
確かに科学者の方々が言っている通りに
脳が結構マネジメントはやってます
細胞のマネジメントやってます
心臓の動き 腸の働き 呼吸器官
見たり聞いたり 体を回されたり
歩いたり座ったり いろんなことをやる場合のマネージャーは脳みそなんですね
だから心はすべて脳はすべてだというのは
ちょっと生命論としてはおかしい
すべての細胞は生きているんです
生きていることが心なんです
だから定義はずれています
科学者がこの考えること
それが心だと勘違いしているんです
計算すること 見たり聞いたり判断したりすること
それが心ですと妄想したり考えたりすること
それは心の一部であって
心とは生きていることなんです
そういうことで定義の差なんですね
脳の機能を学ぶと 心の成長の仕組みも理解できます
はい これからこのガタガタの現代脳科学の概念をちょっと借りて
仏教の心の成長について説明します
まずは仏教の話から始まります
生命の根本衝動 これは科学者は発見していないんです
なんで生きるのかい？と
なんでそんなに生きたがるのかいと
脳で説明できてないでしょう
有為脳で論で何でも説明できるでしょうかと
だったら必死で生きたがることを説明しろよと
脳でどこの辺でしょうかと
お釈迦様は六つの渇愛を教えているんですね
一カマカンナ 五欲ですね
肉体の刺激 肉体から刺激
肉体に刺激があるんですね
これが欲しいんですね
いくらあっても足らないんです
だから渇愛というんです
それからババタンハ 存在欲ですね
生きていきたいという心
生命の衝動 気持ちがあるんですよ
あの 何といいますか アリさんも生きていきたいんですよ
この大脳小脳何もないんだけどね
生きていきたいんです
それから破壊欲ですね
ヴィパッサナー 生命が心であるというと
生命にはこの 3つの衝動があるんです
脳が心というと これはちょっと言いづらくなっちゃうんです
が これから脳ですよという立場で説明はします
これ ３つと分けた場合は ２
つに分ける場合は 根本衝動はアリジャタンハなんです
無明と渇愛ですね 一つだと説明するときもあります
生命が生かされているパワーが一個だけよと
それは無明 無知 すべて心に関わるものなんです
心の能力の問題なんです
それから仏教ではこの無始という単語があります
無限という言葉をあまり使わない
それは仏教は精密に論理ですから
無限という単語は人間に使いませんよという立場なんです
で 過去に対して無始というんです
無始っていうのは始めなきなんですね
無きとか漢字で書くんだけど
仏教では正しく用語が正しい用語なんです
論理的に崩れません 根本衝動に対して
ブッダはコーティ・ナパンニャーエティと説かれるんですね
根本衝動はこの時点から起きたのだと
原始起源を設定することはできない
人間が生きたがる 生命は生きたがる
この根本衝動 生かしてるエネルギーがいわゆる無明ですよ
この時点で始めたよということはちょっと定められませんと
調べても調べても あれは一を三で割ることと同じなんです
一を三で割っても終わりがないでしょう
だから設定できません
だから一を三で割ったような感じで
無明はいつからですかと過去を遡ってみても見ても見てもまたあるんですね
初めはないが 終わりが可能です
生きている衝動には始めはないが
終わりが可能です 終わりを作らなくちゃいかん
始めがないといったら終わりもなくなっちゃうんです
命の創造者 支配者 管理者
無明 無知と渇愛ですね
この命を創造したのは無明と渇愛なんです
管理者も同じですね 無明は無知の衝動
生命は無知の衝動で無知に支配されて
無知の命令で無知のために
無知と渇愛の奴隷として無知に追われて
無知に脅かされて脅されて
自由がなく 無知に束縛されて生きているんです
すべてまとめました 生きることは
何も持てないんです すごいかっこいいですよ
生きることはね 尊いでしょう
命作ったのも無知で無明です
命を管理するのも無明です
命を脅しているのも無知
無明です 生かされているのも無明です
生かされるのは何か目的あるでしょ
無明が何か 無明の目的ですよ
だから無明のためなんです
だから残酷なシステムなんです
そこで他宗教になると
この無明というところに神という言葉を入れるんです
入れて入れ替えてみてください
ぴったし合うんです ぴったし合うんです
他宗教の哲学は 命の創造者
支配者 管理者 全知全能の神であると
合うでしょ 生命は 神の衝動で
神に支配されて 神の指令で神のためにやってるでしょ
そういうことです いかにその方々は無知かとわかりますね
はい 脳の機能から見ましょう
脳の機能から見ると 開発していない
開発できない原始脳の指導で生きている
だからもうスケールがすごく小さくなっちゃったんです
科学者と同じく 私も脳論に戻りました
で 科学者が言ってるんだからね
すべて脳で説明できますよと
では私も脳で説明してみせます
気にする必要ないでしょ
では 脳の場合は大脳と原始脳と小脳って三つありますね
まあ小脳は電線管轄外
聞いたんですけど あんまり脳科学者とも小脳の仕事は何かとまだわからないんですね
まああの 何といいますか
配線を束ねているところやと
全部脳のね 実際仕事をしているのは原始脳と大脳です
そこで私は無知無明ということをイコール原始脳にするんです
で お釈迦様にはすごい侮辱になりますけど
我々にとってはわかりやすいんだからね
仏教にとってそんなことすごい迷惑ですよ
しかししょうがないんです
原始脳が我々の命を支配しているんです
大脳は原始脳が引き起こす指令に合わせて働くんです
で 原始脳が指令出すんです
そうすると大脳が奴隷になって言うとおりにやるんです
で 原始脳にものを見ることはできません
見なくたってもいいんです
世間知らない 真っ暗 地球丸いとも四角いとも三角ともわからないんです
で 原始脳が命令出しちゃうと
大脳が仕事をする 後で出てくると思いますけど
どんな命令出すのかというと
生きていきたいよと だったら勝手に生きればいいでしょうに
大脳生きるんですよ 大脳が物事を調べてみたら
生きていきたいと言ったってもね
そう簡単じゃないよと
大変だと これはと いうことで食べなくちゃいけないわ
呼吸しなくちゃいけないわ
物事を見なくちゃいけないわ
花と草を区別しなくちゃいけないわね
だってクソとミソの区別できなかったら大変なことになるでしょうに
言葉似ているんだからといってね
で そういうことで大脳が奴隷みたいにむちゃくちゃ働くんです
だから我々は耳で音を聞いて判断するのも生きるためなんです
目で物を見て判断するのも生きるためなんです
味にうるさいのも生きるためなんです
食べ物はとって食べればいいのに
料理するんです 毒付けして食べるんです
これ 私の最近流行ってる単語です
料理するとは毒付けですよと
で そのまま食べればいいと言ってしっこりなってるんです
しんこりなっているんです
やっぱり料理したものはね
まあ消化しやすくてたくさん食べられる
そうすると ああ これなら死なないんだそうという風な錯覚に陥る
キャベツを生で食べると
ほんのちょっと食べるともう嫌ですよ
そうすると原始脳が心配で
これでは危ないんじゃないかなとか
全然大丈夫ですけど 全く大丈夫なんですけど
原始脳が怯えるんです
そうするとキャベツをたくさん食べたいんですね
それでまあ作るわ 作るわね
いろんな料理 フードプロセッサーでね
キャベツ半分ぐらい潰しちゃって
これで団子を作って食べちゃうと
キャベツを半分食ったことになっちゃいますからね
大量なんですよ あれ 生きるためにやってます
そんなアホなこと 原始脳が無明だから
これで死 早死は早めるんだということはわからないんです
気づくと後の祭りなんです
心臓が弱くなって 動脈が硬くなって
冠状動脈というんですか
このコロナリアードなんかね
コレステロールはひどくなって
血管にプラークという硬いものができたりして
それで調べるともう手遅れです
これが原始脳がやらせているんです
大脳は知ってます 知ってるんだけど
奴隷だからね 我々は勉強するのも生きるためなんです
原始脳イコール獣の脳と理解した方がいいんです
それで原始脳っていうのは獣にもありますよ
トカゲ脳と言いますからね
レプティリアンブレーンと
で 形全部同じですよ 猫の原始脳とネズミの原始脳と我々の原始脳っていうのは同じものなんです
大きさ違うだけ それは別にどうったことないでしょ
体が大きくなると 脳細胞の数も多くならないと管理できませんだから
だからね 銀行が支店増えるとマネージャーたちも増えるでしょ
銀行は 1箇所しかなければ
マネージャー一人で十分です
だからネズミの原始脳よりは人間の原始脳が大きいんですけど
だからといってこちらの方が上というわけじゃないんです
だから原始脳イコール獣の脳として理解してください
人は感情のままで生きる脳であって
まれな場合以外は理性中心にはならない
これは原始脳の働き これは仏教の見方でもあります
人間 いくら格好つけても感情で生きているんです
より安全にして生きるためにすごいくだらんことをやっています
ただネクタイをつけることさえも
存在欲以外何でもないんです
ネクタイを外したらまずいとか
立場が悪くなるとか 何か言われるかもしれませんとか
失礼だと思われたら困るとかね
これすべて自分の命に関わる問題でしょ
何もやってないんですよ
理性で 猫と同じです で
脳の働きについて 私は専門外ですからね
専門家の研究を参照することを勧めます
それが 脳の働きについて
皆様方は申し訳ないんですけど
本で勉強してください
で 私はその仕事外です
考えたんですよ いろいろ脳のサンプルとかね
まあなんて絵とかね 持ってきて説明しようしようかなと
そうなっちゃうと私は英語になっちゃいますから
日本語の単語知らないんだから
これ私にとってはかなり重労働になっちゃうんです
そういう自分のすごく怠けでカットしたんです
で 有名な本というのは
このブッダズブレーン
ザプラクティカルニューロサイエンスオブハピネスラブアンドウィスダムという本ですね
リックハンソン リチャード
MDメンディスというメンディスという３人の本で
それからマイストロークオブインサイトという女性なんですけど
ジルボルテンテイラー
これ結構仏教に関係ないんだけど
脳の働きから言ってることは見事に
おお なるほどとね 慈しみのこととかね
自我の内側しさとかね
この本でもよく書かれています
私はこのブッダズブレーンという本は結構前読みましたけど
結構立派に書いてますよ
ぴったし仏教に合わせて書いてます
なんか日本訳はそんなに感動的じゃないみたいんですけど
日本訳する場合は 仏教は知ったらかっこ悪いんだから知らないことにするでしょ
でも英語で書いてる人々はちゃんと仏教を学んでる人々なんです
あの そのヨーロッパ人は仏教を知っていることを恥ずかしいと思わないんです
それ日本人だけなんです
それから Brains Buddhas
and Believing The
problem of intentionality
難しいんですよ これ 単語も
これは学問的な本ですね
一般人向けではないと思います In
classical buddhism and cognitive scientific philosophy of mind
わかりますかね  Brains
というのはただ脳みそ
ブッダっていうのはブッダたち
アンドビリービングっていうのは信仰ですね
その 3つのテーマに合わせて Problem
of intentionality という intention というのは
何かやりたいという意欲です
仏教用語なんです 生きていきたいという欲のこと
その意欲についての分析なんです
クラシカルブッディズム
いわゆるクラシカルって何でしたっけ？古典仏教の説明と intention の意思の説明と
現代科学の認識機能 で
ごっちゃまぜにした本です
すごい難しいと思いますから
必ず読んだ方がいいと思います
で また安いんです  4,000円ぐらいです
一応私は買いましたけどね
で この本では皆様は知らない本ですからね
また今日これしか紹介しませんが
結構あります 仏教と脳の比較した本はね
一つ一つも仏教の悪口言ってないんです
この本だけ悪口言ってます
この人はある程度で仏教学者でもあります
学者ですね 日本の仏教学者と同じです
仏教は知らない で この人がこのダルマキーリとか
この大乗仏教の始めた時の大物の方々
ダルマキーティ ナーガルジュナ
そういう人々は 心が別
肉体と別な働きであると説明するんだと
心には死後も存続することはできますよと説かれてますけど
この人々は脳科学を知らなかったんだよと
脳科学で脳科学ではすべてのコグニティブファンクションを説明できますよとなんかいちいち言ってるんです
で 私に会わない方がいいと思いますし
このアーノルドさんがね
で しかし ダルマキーティが何言ったっても私には関係ないし
あるいは大乗仏教の大物の方々ですからね
私はお釈迦様の仏教です
どうせダルマキーリさんも結構立派に仏教心理学分析していますけど
ナーガルジュナさんもすごい立派に哲学を語ってますけど
滑るんですね あんまり出しゃばって
ブッダよりすごいこと言ってやろうといってね
だから大乗仏教を研究する人々は
この超あの人々の脳はまあ並みじゃないんですよ
ダルマキーティさんの脳も
お坊さんたちですけどね
デンナーさんの脳細胞も
ボスバンドの脳細胞もね
今考えたって 私もなんかヘライビビるんですね
なんていう頭でしょうかと
頭はいい だからあれぐらいのテキスト書きましたけど
でしゃばると滑るんです
だから滑ったところを私が言うんだから
みんなに嫌われるんです
あんたナーガルジュナの悪口言いますよと
ナーガルジュナっていうのは菩薩だよと
ナーガルジュナはブッダだよと
だからこの人はそちらに乗り上がったところで
滑ったところで引っかかってても勝手にしろよということでね
ダルマゲートの仏教心理学に対して批判的で
唯の立場で語っている本なんですね
だから賛成派だけじゃなくて
反対派の本も一応紹介しなくちゃあかんだからね
というわけで 私は科学には行かない
しかし 私は原始脳大脳という言葉 2つは使います
あの原始脳と言ったっていくつか部品がありますよ
いろいろ部品があって
それぞれの部品で仕事は違います
そんなこと私の仕事じゃないんです
で 感情を作る部品やらね
もう生存欲やらせるところやらね
それからこのホルモンやらいろんなものを出すところやらね
で もう生命維持する器官ね
必ず働かなくちゃいかん
24時間 そういうところを管理するところで
いろいろいろ専門的に分かれてます
脳と言ったっても別世界ですね
ものすごい別世界です
しかし 目に見えないほんの微かなところですごいことをやってるんですよ
例えば我々バイオ時計を持ってるでしょ？腕時計より小さいんです
で ほんの小さいところなんで見えないぐらい
でも何もないのに見事に
外の情報も入れて体の時計を管理するんです
ただ 日夜管理するだけじゃ足りませんよ
バイオ時計は 我々の時計よりはものすごい仕事があります
だって例えばね  18の時
何をするべきかと  25歳で何するべきかと
50歳でどうするべきかと
全部知り出すためのあれやらないとプログラム管理しなくちゃあかんですよ
だから私たちは髪の毛のことをいくら可愛がったってもね
適当な年になったら落ちるんです
まあ接着剤で貼っておくしかないんです
だから今日は土曜日 明日は日曜日という程度じゃないんですよ
バイオ時計は しかし そんなでっかいところで管理してるわけじゃないんです
ほんのちょっとのいや
僅かな細胞でできます
それだから この原始脳の話を説明しましょう
原始脳とは外の情報を知らない
だから暗闇 思考判断能力はない
存在欲と怯えは基本です
原始脳に存在欲があるんです
怯えがあるんです 成長開発はない
我々とネズミは同じです
ネズミの原始脳と人間の原始脳は全然成長してないんです
大脳とは違います しかし
大脳を人質にして操るんです
こんな馬鹿者に 何の成長もできない
馬鹿者というのは獣ですよ
この獣の脳が大脳を人質にしているんです
大脳はネズミと人間は同じじゃないんです
猫と人間は同じじゃないんです
チンパンジーの大脳と人間の大脳
決して同じじゃないんです
人間の脳が大きいんです
で まあゾウの脳がなんか人間と比較すると結構大きいんですけど
ゾウは話してくれませんだからね
まあ頭がいいはずなんですね
人間よりは まあとにかく脳が成長している人々は
生命はだいたい仲良しなんですね
あんまり敵視しませんよ
例えばね ゾウは至って簡単に人間と馴染み
馴染むし 海のね 哺乳類の動物もね
人間とは簡単に仲良くするんです
脳が大きいんです シャチやらイルカやらね
野生だからやばいということはないんです
はい そういうことで これは原始脳に対して
仏教の坊主である私の見解で説明するとそうなるんです
ちょっと科学とは違いましたと言ったっても気にもしません
あんた科学の方面から見れば
言ってること間違ってますから
黙っていなさいという態度を取るんです
で 仏教の偏見で喋ります
対立したっても意味がないんです
必ず私が勝ちますからね
これはもう自信があります
続きやりましてね 生きていきたい
死にたくはない 敵を倒したい
味方を自分のものにしたいなどの
これ思考じゃないんです
言葉になったら思考ですけどね
などの感情 気持ち だから原始脳には言葉がないんです
なんか気持ちだけ生まれるんで
この気持ちは大脳に行って言語を当てはめるとそうなっちゃうんです
ちょっと理解しにくいんだけどね
生きていきたいと言えば概念であってね
言葉でしょ でも 生きていきたいという気持ちには
単語も言葉も何もないでしょう
ちょっと感じてみてください
言葉じゃないんです 理論も何もないんです
ただ感情 その感情がもう電気ですからね
電気ですから 科学者発見しましたからね
ここで原始脳にパチパチと原始脳が発電するんですよ
いろんな電気種類が それでぺったし一緒ですからね
大脳が あの電気が入っちゃうんです
大脳に 悪いことに大脳が原始脳の上に乗ってるんだから
どこかそこに置いておいた方がね
いいのに そこで大脳の手術できても
原始脳の手術できません
体に放射線を当てても
大脳は壊れるかもしれません
原始脳は壊れません いかないんで
そこまで 脳しようと思ったら
これ大脳に起こるんであって
原始脳にないんです かなりしぶといんです
そこで原始脳の上に乗っかっちゃってるんだからね
もうでっかいんだから
大脳が すっごいでかいんです
だから電気がピシピシと大脳に行くんです
この生きていきたいと
大脳っていうのはしっかりしたもので
生きていきたいと言ったっても
そうはいかないんだよ
ですから 仕事をするは
考えるは 餌を探すは いろんなことをやらなくちゃあかん
死にたくはないと言うんだからね
いろんなことを大脳がやるんです
それで敵を倒したいでしょ
世の中見てください みんなちくちく何やってるんですかね
あらゆる方法で敵を倒すことを考えてるでしょ
ライバルを潰すことを考えてるでしょ
で 死にたくないんだけどね
それはうまくいかないんだからね
科学者たちが 特に医学の研究する人々は必死ですよ
遺伝子研究しながら どんな遺伝子で老化するのかい？とかね
これいじりましょうとかね
改良したら人は老いないでしょうとかね
もしかするとこの命に回数券がありますからね
その回数券の遺伝子を改良すれば人は死なないだろうとか
無茶無茶なことを考えて研究していますよ
だから我々から見ればすごい頭いい研究で
早くやってほしいと思ってるでしょうね
じゃあ原始にやられてるでしょ
あれは原始脳の感情なんです
あの大馬鹿者 獣の原始脳のために奴隷になって働いているだけ
大脳はその指令に従って物事を判断したり
考えたり 行動したりするんです
ですから 大脳にはスーッと葛藤があるんです
大脳が大変なんです 現実を知らない原始脳がの
が わがままな指令を出しても
大脳が世間とコミュニケーションを取って活動しなくてはならない
あちら自分を人質にしてね
金出しなれ出せと言ったっても
出す人にとっては大変でしょ
だから我々の大脳が世間とコミュニケーションして
いろんな苦労をして頑張らなくちゃあかんですよ
だからクタクタ疲れます
生きる時は 死にたくはないが
死ぬのだと大脳は知ってます
だって世間知ってますからね
自分の気持ちね 死にたくない
死にたくないと そんなアホなっていうことを知ってますよ
しかし 必死になって死なないために頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから 死ぬのに死なないために頑張るんです
これは耐えがたい葛藤になるんですよ
だから敵を潰せと言うでしょ
お前なんか嫌だから出て行けと言いたいでしょ
しかし 大脳がね こいつは出て行けと追い出したんだけど
やっぱりこれはまずいわ
やっちゃったらこんな結果になるんだ
世間の目もあるわ もうまあどうしようなぁと我慢するでしょ
あれはすごい脳にとっては葛藤なんですよ
大脳が弱い人はやっちゃいますよ
だからこのすぐ喧嘩する
嫌な人を追い出す このヤクザみたいに
あれは大脳が弱いんですね
この葛藤に耐えられないんですよ
だから誰一人も楽々に生きているわけじゃないんです
皆様方は生きるために会社に行くでしょう
楽ですかね まあ仕事はどうってことないと思いますけど
あの 仕事自体はね しかし大変でしょ
現実的に仕事難しいわけじゃないんです
大変です すーっと大脳が原始脳とちょっと待ってよと
これはまずいやと お前の話聞きますからと
でもあいつぶん殴ったら仕事がなくなっちゃって
食い物なくなっちゃって
奥さんにも捨てられちゃって
苦労するのお前だろうと
だからお前のためにということで
あの葛藤を感じなくちゃいけないんですよ
それで人間が精神的に病気になるんです
この現代心理学で病気だと扱っているのは
この葛藤に耐えられなくなった時なんです
仏教の精神病とはちょっとレベルがものすごく低いんですけど
葛藤に耐えている間は
現代心理学では病気ではありません
夫婦喧嘩もね ずっと我慢して我慢して
やっぱり葛藤に耐えられなくなっちゃったら
まあ原始の言う通りにやっちゃいます
電車で痴漢する人々もね
原始のは欲ですからね
やれやれと言ってるんですよ
でも大脳でそんなことやったら大変だと
全部パーになっちゃうんだと言って抑えるんですよ
やっぱりやがてもう耐えられないんですよね
葛藤に それですぐ痴漢しちゃう
すぐ人を刺す 大脳の中で絶えない葛藤が起き続けています
寝ても起きるんです それは夢を見ると
この寝るということは何なのか
私もよくわからないんですよ
だって体寝ないのに私たちは寝るでしょ
私にとってこれおかしくて
寝るって何なのかと 細胞は生きているし
呼吸はしているし 消化しのをちゃんとやっているし
心臓も動いているし 一つもメスじまいしてないんですよ
コンビニと同じ 24時間やってますよ
体が なのに寝るんですね
寝るって何ですかね すごいシンプルです
寝た夢見てない間はこの葛藤がないんです
それだけ その時は原始脳の命令で体を維持管理すれば十分です
世間のことを気にする必要はないんです
だからみんな寝たいでしょう
あれも病気になりますけど
寝たがるのは短い時間でも
この脳の葛藤をストップしたいんですよ
仏教はその葛藤をなくす方法っていうのは結構プロです
だから寝ることは推薦しません
もっとすごい面白い 葛藤なく 24 時間で生きられる方法がありますよ
いじめられる大脳 生存と敵を倒すことに協力しなくてはいけない
生きるために頑張らなくちゃいけないし
敵を倒すために頑張らなくちゃいけない
例えば 生きるために戦争に行くでしょ
矛盾だらけでしょうに
鉄砲持って人殺しに行ったら
向こう側から殺されるでしょうに
なんでもないことですかね
やってますよ アメリカはいろんな国で戦争を起こすんだけど
我は偉いやとかね アメリカの生存のために世界中どこでも戦争してやるぞと威張ってますけど
大いに被害を受けるのは誰ですかね
アメリカの若者たちでしょ
第三世界ではね もう家が潰れたって
もともと大した家ではなかったし
そんなに感じないんですよ
贅沢に生きている人々は
足もなくなって それから被爆したりして
はい そういうことで脳が大変ですよ
いじめられています 知識
能力 技術 言語などを学ばなくてはいけないんですね
あの言語を学ぶのも原始脳の衝動なんです
でなかったら人間喋れませんよ
何も教えなかったら我々は何も喋れません
言葉を喋るのは人間の特色と言ったっても
そうじゃないんです 学ぶんです
言葉は それはすべてが欲
怒りという 2種類の能力です
そういうわけで 我々の大脳が作っているこの世界
あの日本の先生の名前何でしたっけ？あの脳の先生は
養老先生 養老先生もおっしゃってるように
この町やら世界やら 全部これ脳が作っているんだよと
まあその通りですけど
脳の中で作っているんです
全部 しかし 全部 2つに分けられます
欲と怒り すべての学問
欲と怒りに分けられます
その上 原始脳は実行不可能
感情の命令まで出しっぱなしなのです
それも制御しなくてはいけない
感情が出すだけで ほとんど実行不可能なものをたくさん出しますよ
皆さんはもね 億万長者になりたいとかね
世界一人気者になりたいとか思ってない？思ってください
なれないんですけどね
まあ空を飛びたいとかね
まあ結構実行不可能なことをね
命令するんですよ 知ってますか？なんで人間が超能力好きですかね
超能力ないんだけど 世の中で
日本では結構いるんですね
何の力もないやつらですけど
えらく超能力あるよと言い張っているんです
何々さんが何 過去世で何々でしたとか言ったりして
あの歴史本とか何とか調べて言うんです
あれ 超能力でも何でもないんです
日本の総理は過去世でなんとかなんとか人でしたとか
よくみんな知ってる範囲で喋ってるんです
だからまあ騙されるんだからいいと思いますけど
みんな で なんで騙されますかと
皆様方もやっぱり過去世知ったりした方がありがたいなと思っているんです
なんで人間が必死になって神に祈るんですかね
まあ日本はないんだけどね
アメリカなら 激しいうるさい
どこででも祈っているんです
アメリカでは勝手に生殖しちゃくなりますからね
なって いろんなところで祈りするわ
金集めるわ 祈りする 金集めるとかね
あの あの特別な能力好きなんですよ
欲しいんです 神が介入してきて
なんか不可思議なこと
奇跡を起こしてほしいんです
こんなアホなことをやっているのは
これもう恥ずかしいんですよ
では 私のハンドパワーで何時の病気を治してあげる
何時のがんを治してあげるとかね
一人も治してないんだけど
でも信じる人はたくさんいるんです
あれが原始脳の指令です
病気がひどいんです 子供はちっちゃい時
シンデレラ物語は読んで喜びますけど
大人になっちゃうと忘れちゃいますよ
信じてないんです 子供によって
なんで神話物語が面白いかというと
なんで怪獣物語 なんで漫画が面白いとか
なんでアンパンマンはすごい人気かというと
人間とは大人と違って子供は全然信じてないんです
しっかりしているんです
だから面白いんですよ
だって嘘だから何言ったってもいいんだから
大人勘違いしてます 本当に子供は信じているんだと
信じてないんです だからぬいぐるみに向かってね
お前ね 名前もつけて 何々ちゃんも今日しっかりこの何々ちゃん守ってあげてねとか言ったら
子供にくっと笑っちゃうんですね
あれ 嘘だからなんです
だから大人もよくバカになってぬいぐるみでしゃべると子供はもうよく受けます
しかし 子供の次元に入って言うともっと受けますよ
子供は心の本音言います
その時は ある子供とブロックで何か建物
家を作りましょうよと言うと
この子供はブロックを合わせて普通の何とか家とか屋根とかセットありますからね
作っていると 私はあのね
これ面白くないやと 絶対ありえない家作らなくちゃいかんやと
これが倒れるんだと こんな家は作れませんよ
それが面白いやと言って
それわからないんだから
まあちょっとだったらね
ちょっと 1本の柱ぐらい立てて
これで伸ばして伸ばして伸ばして伸ばして
これからちょこっと作って
なんとかなんとかなんとか家作りましょうよと
ちょっとってことで倒れちゃいますと
そうするとすごく興味を出すんですよ
本当の遊びっていうのは
いかに現実離れするのを帰っておくことやと
それは精神的な病気にならないんです
それはもう思考能力も上がるし
脳も開発します で 大人があの病気がまた現れてきて
結構超能力好き 超能力で病気治してほしい
祈りを聞いてほしい 神が子供の試験を合格させてほしいとか思っちゃうんです
そういう希望も原始脳が出すわけもわからない
実行不可能な希望なんです
こんなことを出すと困るのは大脳なんです
やられます 金が取られます
いろんな組織に束縛されます
そんなひどい目に遭ったりします
だからまあ空を飛びたいなと
黒板長になりたいなとか希望があったっても
そんなアホなっていうことで終了しなくちゃあかんです
物事は壊れる 命は成り立たない
生きるために努力してもうまくいかないという現実があります
大脳が様々な幻覚 妄想
迷信などを作って原始脳を騙さなくてはいけないんです
だってこの物事は壊れるってことは
原始脳にわからない 理解できないでしょ
あの原始脳の働き 発見する一つ例を出します
皆様 飼っている猫の前で名前で呼んで
ね  2 たす 2 はいくつですかと聞いてみてください
ちゃんと 2 と 2 じゃあいくつ？わかると思う
教えられると思う 不可能です
我々の原始脳なんてそのレベルなんです
何も理解できないんです
何も だから物事は壊れるんだと大脳知ってますよ
もう壊れますよ 家を作ると自然を破壊しなくちゃあかんですよ
資源を取りましょうと思ったら
自然破壊しなくちゃあかんですよ
だから壊れることはもう毎日大脳は知ってますけど
誰でも命っていうのは成り立たんやと
ちょっとしたことで死ぬんだと
だから我々は階段を下りる時も
私もこの階段を上がる時はちゃんと段を見ながら上がってきたんです
それだけでも死んじゃいますからね
まあ皆様助かりますけど
講演はできなかったんだから
あちら死んじゃってね
もう でもなんか残念なことに転がなかったんです
で ちょっとした階段転がっちゃっても死ぬ可能性あります
命成り立たない で それが大脳に教えられますかね
極限に無知だから教えられないんです
だから大脳 いいや いいや
いいやと言ってあげないと
大丈夫 大丈夫と言ってあげないと大変です
獣ですから それで大脳がうまいことやっちゃいますよ
いろんな幻覚を作るんです
妄想するんです 例えば
死んでも魂は死にませんとか
知ったんですかね あんなのは
大脳で 何のデータもなく
大脳はそんなことでしゃばったこと言える？言うはずがないです
あれは妄想するんです
妄想せざるを得ないんです
迷信を作るんです あの神社に大根 2本お供えすれば
商売繁盛するんだと あの神社には酒
二升瓶 三升瓶ぐらいお供えすれば
これこれこれとか そういういろんな迷信を作っちゃうんです
だから原始脳がダラダラと活動しているのは西洋文化なんです
大脳に何の立場もないんです
えらい知識ぶってますけど
全部欲と怒り  2つだけです
それから神 それから迷信
それからチャネリングするんですね
幽霊と死んだ霊とかね
それでイギリスから学んで
日本でも胸を張ってやっているとんでもない病気の連中がいるんです
お父さんからの手紙とか
そういうことをして 我々は原始脳を事実わからないんだけど
騙しておくんです だから大脳が幻覚を作ったら
俺は年取って死んでも阿弥陀様が迎えに来る
どうせ極楽道にいる 行く
あ 心配するなよと それで大脳が落ち着くと
原始脳はもう落ち着くんです
でも死にます 極楽道に行こういけないか
それはわからない 変化する現象をひとたびにまとめるために
自我という錯覚を作らなくてはいけない
特に大脳 大変ですよ データがすーっと変わるんですよ
自分の赤ちゃんでも毎日変わっていくんです
別人になっちゃうんですよ
これで別人 別人 別人と思ったらもうおっかないでしょ
それで同じ人にするんです
それで自我が出てくるんです
自分がいるんだという錯覚を作るんです
でないと無常とは付き合いなくなっちゃうんです
大脳にありのままに情報を知ることはできますが
生存欲の原始脳の人質なので
自分の都合に合わせてデータを捏造したり合成したりする
大脳にデータありのままに
科学的に客観的に見る能力はあるんです
でも大脳にやられちゃった
やられているんだから
それでデータは見ない
捏造するんです 花を見ると
植物の生殖器官で見えません
あ 美しい花です なんて綺麗ですかってなっちゃうんです
ヘビの死骸を見たら ああ
気持ち悪い 食欲もなくなったと思うんです
それで魚の死骸を見たら
ああ これ結構美味しいですよ
油で揚げたらというんです
死骸でしょうに で スコーピオンは何でしたっけ？日本語でサソリ
サソリとかモカデとかね
見たら気持ち悪くて しかしもっとグロテスクですけど
カニなんかは毛ガニとかはね
おいっと思っちゃいますけど
でも美味しいでしょう
よだれが出るんですね
だからあれは自分たちの都合なんです
ものすごいかっこ悪い魚ですよ
アンコウという魚が 鬼の顔ですよ
あれは でも気持ち悪いと誰も思ったことないでしょ？私が病気ですかね
なんでですかね あれは
美しい魚っていうのは結構いるでしょうに
はい そういうことで 私たちは人間に必要なものだけねつ造して都合で見るんです
ゴキブリを見たら食べ物で見えませんね
しかし 鳥があっ 食べ物ということで見るんですね
こういうふうに このいじめられた大脳が真理を知れるのに知りません
知ろうともしない ねつ造しなきゃもうダメです
人質にされているんです
ありのままではなく あってほしいままに認識するんです
知識は増えるが 真理は知らない
間違った知識ばっかり増えるんですけど
すーっとバカのままなんです
原始脳に打ち勝てっこはないんです
原始脳で汚染される それで大脳は汚染されます
原始脳の欲 怒り 恐怖 無知などの感情で大脳も汚染します
別に大脳にないんです
そんなのは ないんだけど
原始脳で怒りの電気が生まれたら
恐怖の電気が生まれたら
さっと大脳に入っちゃうんです
我々は知っているのは大脳に現れる汚れだけです
皆さんは怒りがあるとか知ってるでしょ？欲は良くない
嫉妬は良くないとか知ってるでしょ？なんか私が嫉妬してるみたいなところ実感もあるでしょ
あれは大脳のものなんですよ
大脳に原始脳から嫉妬が入ったら自分でも知ってます
原始脳にある時は知らないんです
だから我々は 24時間受けているわけじゃないんですね
24時間嫉妬してるわけでもないんですね
24時間愚痴こんでるわけでもないんですね
だから大脳の電気信号
原始脳の電気信号で大脳が汚染されるたびに気づいたり気づかなかったりします
気づいた方が安全ですよ
ほとんど気づかないんだからね
それも そこまでくったくたにいじめられているんです
どこまでかというと 怒るのは正しいんだと
敵は殺すのは手前ではないかと
そこまで壊れているんです
大脳が 罪も悪も命を危う状態に陥れる
苦 行為もすべて大脳が原始脳の脅しで正当化するんです
で 生きていきたいために生きているのに
やっていることでは生きていられないんでしょ
会社の金をごまかすわ
公で嘘を言うわ 文書をごまかすわ
いろんな悪いことやってます
怒るわ 嫉妬するわ 痴漢するわ
空き巣に入るわ ひったくりするわ
人を殺すわ 非でない あんなことで生きていられないでしょ
だから感染されてますよ
大脳が わがままな大脳です
すみません 原始脳にわがままな原始脳に感染されています
お金欲しい それだけ欲しいものは取れ
言ったら空き巣に入る
大脳にもできない 葛藤できない
忍耐できない 耐えられない
やっちゃいます そこで大脳はこれ正当化するんですよ
弁解するんですよ 我々は罪を犯して
すぐ弁解するんです だってしょうがないもんとかね
だって先に手を出したのは向こうでしょうにとかね
いつでもだって来るんですよ
これが現実でしょ こんなことやってはいけないのに
支配者が無知だからやります
汚染された時 感情で汚染されると
認識機能 判断能力 思考能力などは衰えます
いわゆる大脳に仕事をできなくなります
嫉妬 怒り 憎しみ 落ち込み
欲 こんな感情が下から湧いてきて
大脳いっぱいになったら
脳が機能低下するんです
衰えます それから壊れます
大脳が 生存欲に反対の結果になります
で 生きていられなくなります
それも脳の機能低下も
大脳にとっては苦痛なんです
苦しみを味わわなくちゃかんです
例えば やってはいけないことをやるでしょ
それからなんでこんなことをやったのかいと
ものすごく苦しみを感じるんです
それから 怒り 嫉妬で脳が機能しないでしょ
あれ すごい苦痛なんですよ
皆様に経験ないかもしれませんだけど
うつの方々を見てください
うつっていうのは脳の機能低下なんです
大脳の 楽しくないでしょ
まあキラキラで明るくニコニコ笑っている方が気持ちいいでしょ
うつになったら笑わないでしょ
本人たちがものすごい苦痛を感じるんです
だから脳の機能低下はね
とんでもないことなんですよ
それから激しいストレスになります
あのお医者さんがなんか変なことを言いますけど
ストレスなしで生きていられませんとかね
ストレスなく生きていられますけど
このストレスというのは
この原始脳の命令に大脳がやられることなんです
苦労しなくちゃいけないことなんです
はい それから原始脳について語ったんだけど
原始脳の機能を発見しなくちゃいけない
原始脳を見たければ 誰か本を開けて見てください
見たっても物体だから何の意味もないんだよ
物質でものを考えるのは現代知識人だからね
我々は機能で考えるんです
原始脳の形はどうでもいいんです
機能で発見するんです
では 機能で発見させます
わかってはいるが やめられないね
怒ってはいけないが怒ってしまう
努力しなくてはいけないが怠けてしまう
嫌われることを知っているのに地がある
経験ない 何の理由もなく怒る
この衝動は原始脳です
嘘は言ってはいけないんだけど
ついちゃうでしょ 若者は勉強しなくちゃいけないの
知ってるんだけど勉強しないでしょ
原爆しちゃいけないと知ってるんだけど
やっちゃうでしょ タバコ吸ってはいけないとわかってるのにやっちゃいますね
理由を聞いたら理由もないんです
なんであんたはあの人のこと嫌いですかと
知らない そういう理由がなく起こる働き
すべて原始脳から生まれるんです
大脳が起こったら理由を言うんです
原始脳が起こったら理由がないんです
例えば 子供がこちらに来て
もう私は怪獣やと思って怪獣に仕上げてもう蹴ったりする
これはこれでもかい これでもかいとかね
まあ子供に蹴られても一回二回ぐらいはもう大丈夫ですけど
これ十回ぐらいやっちゃうと相当痛いんですよ
もう耐えられないんですね
そうするとこれは何やってるのかと怒るでしょ
それで私に聞いてください
あのね なんであなたが子供に怒ったんですかと
理由があるんです あいつはもう終わりなく蹴るんだから
痛いんですよと だから怒ってあげたんだと
その場合は大脳が怒ったんです
だって最初は別に怒る気持ちはなかったしね
どんどん痛くなってくるわ
子供ももう調子というか
もう程度知らないわ どこまで行くかわからないわということで判断して怒るんですね
そういうことで 皆様にも各自で自分の原始脳の機能を発見できます
簡単です これ仏教用語で潜在煩悩というものがあるんですね
アヌセーヤというんですね
で これは原始脳の働きですね
七つです 仏教はすごいでしょう
はっきり数字で言いますよ
いえ 違う 五つだよと言える人だったら言ってよと
原始脳の中で繁殖する感情で気づくことができません
この潜在煩悩っていうのは原始脳の姿なんです
これはお釈迦様以外 誰にも発見できません
我々も言葉を聞いたら知ってますけど
あれは原始脳から大脳に来てからなんです
一 カーマーラーガーアヌセヨ
欲愛ですね 欲 この性欲も入ります
二 パティガーナ パティガーアヌセヨ
これは心に寝ているんです
適当な時現れます ディッターヌですよ
見解 あの見解といえば
なんか哲学っぽくて頭がいいわけでしょ？じゃないんです
これ見解っていうのは潜在煩悩なんです
偏見的で なんか変ですよ
これは すごいあのぶち切っちゃうんですよ
疑い どうかなどうかな
どうせどうでしょう どうでしょうという気持ち
いわゆるこの感情ですよ
なんか皆様もはっきり物事言わないでしょ
自分の立場を守りたくてね
あれは必ずこういう煩悩なんです
イエスって言ったらまずいんだからね
いやって言ったらまずいんだから
ああ まあどうでしょうかね
まあまあね という これで会話進みます
進みますからね マーナーですよ
マンっていうのは この俺
自分という自我ですね
ババラーがですよ これ存在欲
七無明 一番基本的なのは無明で
それは一番下でなかなか取れないんです
一応この順番で この七数で
この順番というのはこの取り消される順番でもあります
最後に無明を取り消すんです
その時は完全な悟りで阿羅漢果なんです
ね 自分にあるとは誰もが気づかない感情です
しかし この煩悩が大脳を刺激するとあることに気づくが
なぜこのように感情的になったのかと理由は成り立ちません
で怒るんだけど 理由はもうわからなく怒る場合あるでしょ
理由もなく食い過ぎちゃったりする時もあるでしょ
そうやって理由もなく
なんかやめられない状態でいる時は
潜在煩悩が大脳に入っているんです
例えばもう殺す世界でももう殺しまくっちゃうんですよ
このテロリストたちとかは
なんかやめられなくなるんですね
その時はもう潜在煩悩が大脳に入って働き出しています
はい 最終的に言えるのは
脳っていうのは心ですから
病気です 完全に病気です
何一つもいいところはないんです
精神病で悩まない生命はいないと説かれています
お釈迦様は明確におっしゃっています
人間がみんな精神病だよと
現代心理学の立場とはそれ違いますね
無明で働く原始脳は精神病の大本です
だからこのがんそのものなんですね
原始脳が 精神病の これが病巣なんです
そこからスーッと大脳を感染して病気にするんです
大脳の場合は病気になったりならなかったり様々ですけど
まあそれでもやっぱり病気ですよ
原始脳はそのまま これは摘出するしかないんです
完璧に それにいじめられている大脳も常に精神病にかかっているんです
はい これでちょっと休憩しましょう
それでお釈迦様があの外科ではないんだからね
この機能で内科ですからね
機能で説明しなくちゃいけない
だから心の機能で説明して
それからこの どうやってこれ開発するのかと
そこで脳から見ると 私は今だから原始脳に開発ないんです
成長しないんです 大脳ですよ
我々は大脳の2割しか使ってないんです
それもろくに機能しないんです
ゴミが入って お釈迦様のプログラムでは
大脳は全部使えるようになる
それから原始脳を摘出することできないでしょ
機能ストップさせるんです
完璧によけなきゃ 機能ストップさせたら
あれは生き物だからね
おとなしく自分の仕事をするんです
いわゆる体のいろんな臓器
部品 部品を管理しなくちゃいかんですよ
それだけやってるんです
人質は終わり 人質にしたら
もうあいつを助けてあげたら
あの人犯罪者でしょ 閉じ込めなくちゃいかんでしょ
そのプログラムがお釈迦様がちゃんとできるように説かれてあります
開発できるの大脳です
生きるという仕事をしているのも大脳です
原始脳は生きていきたいだけで
生きているのは大脳の仕事なんです
脳の本来のプログラムを新たなプログラムで置き換えることをします
はい 今まで大脳が原始脳の命令で動いただけです
ただ生きていきたい それで終わり
話は それから敵を倒す
で ごちゃごちゃなことをしていたんですね
認識はしないわ ねつ造するわ
幻覚作るわ 信仰作るわ
もうハチャメチャ 科学発展するわ
いろんなことをやっても
それ全部原始脳の命令でやってるんです
一旦その仕事を辞めさせてもらうんです
脳が生きるために働いています １
それを一旦やめてみるのです
心の清浄に働かせるんです
脳にちょっと仕事を変えて
別な仕事に なんて言えば会社でよく言うでしょ
部を変えちゃうんです
えっ？えっ？はい はい
移動 移動でも同じ仕事も変える
別なセクションに別なところに入れちゃうんですね
ん？ん 天？転属 させるんです
で 皆さんも知ってるでしょう
例えばもう7  8年 10
年ぐらいある仕事をしていて
会社が別な転属させちゃうと相当困るでしょ
もうわからないんだから
何もどうやればいいかと
それでどんな仕事をさせるのかというと
生きるためではなくて
心の汚れを落とすことにちょっと頑張ってくださいと
で 汚れがあっても生きてられますよ
今まで汚れで生きてきたんです
汚れ 怒りで嫉妬で憎しみで無知で無明で
そういう感情があったんだから生きてきたんです
ちょっと待って あなたは転属させます
心清らかにしましょう
サチッタパリヨダパナンエタンブッダナサーサナ
ブッダの教えとは 自分の己の心を清浄することであると一行で語られています
すごいでしょう 脳の説明から言ったっても
ということは 目的を変えてあげるんです
生きる目的を変えるのですが
その代わりに別な大胆な目的をセットします
転属したら転属になったら惨めになったわけじゃないんです
降格したわけじゃないんです
すごい職業 職業になっちゃったんです
もうどうすればいいかわからない言うんだけど
すごくいい職業と仕事なんです
例えば 日本の会社で仕事していた人が突然人形の本社に飛ばされたと
それで仕事の内容も違うんだと
大変ですけど 一応立ち回るんです
それはいろんな言葉でね
心の清浄 人格向上 智慧の開発
煩悩を断つ 解脱を体験する
苦しみを乗り越える 究極の幸福に達するなどの同義語がたくさんあります
名前はどうでもいいんです
今までと違う仕事をさせるんです
生きるためではなく 心を清らかにするために頑張りなさいと大脳に命令するんです
これが原始脳はしませんよ
それで仏教を学んで 大脳で理解して
それで自分の大脳がその自分で転属しなくちゃあかんです
じゃ 私がこの仕事をやってみますと
で 転職した時点で全て変わるようになるんです
まず心の葛藤がなくなるんです
だから しかし 誰でもお釈迦様の修行はやりたくないんです
儀式なら宗教 儀式 祈祷だったらやりたいんです
お祭りならやりたいんです
賛美歌なら歌いたいんです
原始の言うことならやりたいんです
原始脳の言うことを聞かないで
別な仕事をしなさいと言ったら
やりたがらないんです
はい その具体的に言えば
道徳と慈しみがあるんです 2
番目は道徳と慈しみ  1番目は転属すること
2番目は道徳と慈しみ
この道徳っていうのは面白いもので
五戒守るとかね あれは何か生きること
生きるためにというわけじゃないんです
なんかやりづらいんですよ
魚は釣りませんとかね
窃盗しませんと 窃盗した方が生きやすいんです
嘘をついた方が生きやすいんです
しかし 心が汚れるでしょう
それでお釈迦様が本能ならやりたがらない
しかし やらなくちゃいけない項目を道徳として語られています
これが真理であって 普遍的な真理だから
やったら悪い結果は出ません
一石二鳥になるんです
心も清らかになるし 幸福に生きたいという原始脳の切望も叶っているんです
幸せに生きてられます
そこで脳が安らぎを感じる
葛藤がなくなる そこで慈しみ
慈しみでこの脳の錯覚を破るんですよ
原始脳が生きていきたいだけで無明はあるんだけど
この無明だから大脳が自我という錯覚を作るんです
自我が大脳で起こるんです
あの あのビューティフルマインドなんとかというね
あの本で そこを右脳が作るんだと
作って喧嘩するんだと
だから思考もリーニアルシンキング
パラレルシンキングという
この順番を追って考えること
全部まとめて考える これは
左脳が 1 からもう順番で思考する
右は全体的にパーッと理解するというね
だからまあそれぞれ働きはあの本で説明してやります
で 自我の錯覚を破ってほしいんです
それには慈しみが一番やりやすいんです
それから慈しみを実践すると
日常生活は楽々 敵もなくなっちゃうし
みんな協力してくれるし
物事はうまくいくし そうすると原始脳が興奮しなくてもいいんです
原始脳の命令聞いてないんだけど
原始脳が周り見ると あ
うまくいってるじゃんということになるんです
焦りがなくなっちゃうんです
そのそれで修行が始まるんです
理性を駆使して行うんです
その時 必ず理性を使わなくちゃいけない
ただ 私は生命殺しませんではなくて
こういう理由で 今 ブッダの教えをちょっと試しているところだから
だって生命は殺してはあかんでしょうにと
殺されたくないでしょうにと
そういう風にただ馬鹿みたく守るんじゃないんです
道徳は いっそでも理由を考えて理性で守る
慈悲の瞑想も理性を保ちながらやらなくちゃいけないんです
三 思考 妄想 雑念を制御する
それらは原始脳の感情でやむを得ず起こるんです
あの思考やら妄想やら雑念などは
あの原始脳の感情で感染されちゃって起こるものなんです
ろくなものじゃないんです
だから思考妄想しちゃうと
原始大脳が病気そのものなんです
だからそこをやめた方が大脳が健康になるんです
だから次の訓練は思考妄想を抑えることです
四 集中力を上げる この原始脳のせいで生命に集中力がないんです
原始脳が焦ってるんです
怯えているんです 怯えがある限り集中力はないんです
そこで原始脳は あ うまくいってるじゃんと思ってるんだから
集中力を上げるチャンスなんですよ
集中力を上げると 原始脳
集中力っていうのは 原始脳が活性化している
トラブルなく動く よりコンディションがよろしい
これがえらい気持ちいいんですよ
脳がすごい活性化してコンディションが良くなると
ものすごいんです 体のコンディションと違います
五 ありのままに観察する能力を育てる
あのね そうやめてちょうだいと
次に言うんですのに で
こんな風に書いたのは
まあこの講演に合わせたんですけど
これ何やと隠す 何を隠そう
これは私たちはしょっちゅう言ってる
ヴィパッサナー瞑想のプログラムなんです
だから皆様できる時間があったら瞑想会に参加して学んで
一人一人で瞑想してください
ブッダの瞑想は 脳の開発プログラムそのものなんです
そこでこの観察能力といって
我々は実況中継することを教えるんです
実況 中継すると寝相できなくなっていくんです
じわじわじわじわと これが厳しい戦いになります
いまだ勝ってやったことがないんだから
大脳を人質にしている原始脳が簡単に諦めることはしません
できない もう全部パイプラインできてますから
原始脳から大脳へと 神経
神経回路ができているんです
だから結構大変な戦いになります
しかし 実践を始めたら
原始脳のわがままに対して
対応してないのです ブッダのヴィパッサナー実践を始めたっていうことは
原始脳を馬鹿にしたっていうことです
対応しない だからずっと対応して
無になる過去から対応してきたんだからね
修行者にとっては あ これ大変だと感じます
徐々に原始脳との連絡を控えてカットするまで成長するんです
ヴィパッサナー実践始めた途端
原始脳とコミュニケーションを取らないんです
控えるんです 控えて 控えて
控えて 控えて 無視して
無視して 無視して やがてカットするんです
コミュニケーションの
原始脳の命令は受けません
受信しない それで瞑想終了です
いまだかつてやらなかった仕事なので大変ですが
脳が力強くなります 新しい神経回路が現れます
それらは原始脳の信号をオーが抜けてますけど
受信しません 今まで今は原始脳の信号だけで受信するの
原始脳の信号を受信して世界で生きてるんです
だからみんなわがままなんです
迷惑なんです 生きること自体も
今度は原始脳の受信は受けません
大脳で判断するんです
逆に原始脳に信号を送ります
大脳が原始脳に信号を送るようになるんです
大脳が完全に支配権を取って安定したところでプログラム終了です
これが悟りという境地です
そこで大脳には物事を見えるわ
知っているわ 開発できるわ
悪いことやましいことはやりたくないわ
原始脳やられてますからね
これで原始脳の信号をカットして
大脳から新しい配線するんです
原始脳に だから完璧にその人だけ信頼できるんです
嘘をつかないではなくて
つけない 怒らないではなくて怒れない
慈しみの実践しなくちゃではないんです
慈しみでいる すべて姿勢になるんです
素晴らしい世界があるんです
怒れない 欲張れない 嫉妬は生まれない
ライバルがいても 自分の足を引っ張る人がいたっても
何かあなたに助けてあげることはあるの？と聞ける
聞こえる 聞くことできる
これも本気 罪はしません
起こしません その気にもならない
だから完全に心清らかになるんです
だから我々は脳で言えば
原始脳から配線されている配線をストップして
徐々に上から新たな配線を
大脳から原始脳に配線を作らなくちゃあかんです
しかし それは大変なプログラムで
原始大脳のほとんどの細胞を使う羽目になります
それからこのアビダンマテキスト
それから出ると思いますけど
その最後のテキストにヴィパッサナー知恵というセクションがあるんです
いわゆるヴィパッサナー瞑想をすると知恵が現れます
九つも言うし 十とも言うし
七つともいろいろ数字がバラバラですけど
観察実戦を行うと十種類の知恵が現れると説かれてあります
で この十種類は私はもうテキストで説明したんだから
今日はもう時間ないんです
ありのままに観察すると真理が現れになってきます
今までも真理知られる能力はあったんだけど
ねつ造ばっかしで 人質ですからしょうがないでしょ
今度はありのままに見る
そうするとありのままの世界見えてくる
真理を発見できる 生きることが無意味で苦であると発見します
すべては無常で流れる現象であると発見します
自我が成り立たないことをが発見します
これ脳がやってるおかしいこっちゃと成り立たないんだとよく発見します
今まで 要するに今まで騙されていた原始脳にと発見することです
それであの欲 嫉妬 怒り
憎しみと何か機能的に
合うなんか感情みたいなものなんで
智慧が それが現れると原始脳がきれいになっちゃうんです
原始脳は感情器官だから
それしかできないんだだから感情と似たもので置き換えなくちゃあかんです
智慧は入ります 智慧というんですけど
だから仏教の智慧っていうのは知識じゃないんです
智慧とは知識ではなく
感情の次元が超越することです
欲を超越する 怒りを超越する
智慧によって原始脳のすべての感情がなくなっていくんです
なくなっていくんだけど
その代わりに素晴らしいもので代表するんです
代表するものに智慧というんです
で ヴィパッサナー智慧は感情の解毒剤のような働きです
感情に対する解毒剤 生きる目的で作られている脳のプログラムを削除されます
ブッダの瞑想をすると
皆様の脳が完全削除されます
生きることは絶望するべきものではなく
最大の脅威であると発見するので
解脱に達するんです それで解脱を経験するんです
だから現代脳科学者たちが体の働きは何でも脳で説明できますよと言ったら
では解脱まで私は説明してあげたんです
彼らにはそこまではできません
本を書いた方々にもここまでは説明できません
原始脳は完全に解毒されます
ブッダの瞑想で原始脳が完全に解毒されます
し 大脳が完全に開発します
それで生きる目的ですよ
だってでっかい脳が持って生まれたんだけど
これで何やるんですかね？何やる
言葉悪いんだけど これはブッダの瞑想実践するために付いてるんだと思ってください
はい これで終わりです
話は いきなり 時間的な問題もありますので
時間は過ぎましたからね
はい どうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました
さらに皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
戒をまもり 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンニティをイバンジャントサンバローゴーウィナッソト
マーテーバワットアンタラーヨスティーディーガーユコーガバ
ボートサッブマンダランガックアンドサッブデヴァタサッブサッブブッダヌーバヴェーナサッブダンマヌーバヴェーナ
サッブサンガーヌーバヴェーナサダースッティバワントゥティーアビワダナシーリッサニッチャンワンダーパチャイノー
チャッターローダンマワッダンティアユワンノー
スカンバラン ありがとうございます